[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
recommencez j'ai une question
primordiale à vous poser
est-ce que vous avez pensé à bien
nourrir vos besoins ce matin
j'imagine que si je vous dis ça comme ça
de but en blanc vous pensez tout de
suite aux besoins
d'amour
et j'aimerais vous convaincre que la
plupart de nos problèmes relationnels
viennent de besoins insatisfaits
alors quand je vous parle de besoins
bien sûr vous pensez tout de suite aux
besoins physiologiques parce que cela
vous n'avez pas pu échapper depuis que
vous êtes né depuis le jour de votre
naissance vous avez appris que
fallait y aller
il y a besoin de boire les besoins de
manger le besoin de dormir le besoin de
faire pipi et
là avec l'adrénaline avec le stress moi
je sens bien j'ai besoin j'ai besoin
mais c'est pas de cela dont je vais vous
parler je vais vous parler des besoins
psychologiques mais pourquoi je fais le
rapprochement avec les besoins
physiologiques c'est que ça marche de la
même manière sauf que les besoins
psychologiques on s'en rend moins compte
et on va mettre en place des
comportements qu'on appelle des
comportements limitants
c'est important de prendre ça en compte
pourquoi parce que c'est les deux revers
de la même médaille ces besoins
psychologiques comme les besoins
physiologiques si on n'arrive pas à les
nourrir positivement et ben on va les
nourrir quand même c'est à dire
négativement
et c'est de ça dont je voudrais vous
parler aujourd'hui pour que peut-être on
mettre plus de conscience sur comment
nous satisfaisons des besoins de manière
positive plutôt que d'aller les chercher
de manière négative c'était hyper qui le
premier à parler de comment justement
nous arrivions à nourrir nos besoins de
manière négative plutôt que de manière
positive il a établi une espèce de carte
des besoins et il a pris huit besoins
psychologiques dont il a démontré la
satisfaction positive et la satisfaction
négative il y a besoin de reconnaissance
pour son travail
le besoin de structuration du temps le
besoin de reconnaissance en tant que
personne le besoin sensoriel le besoin
de contact le besoin de solitude le
besoin d'excitation et le besoin de
reconnaissance pour ses opinions c'est 8
besoins là il a montré comment s'ils ne
sont pas satisfaits positivement ils
vont l'être quand même c'est à dire
négativement
je me souviens il y a quelques années
j'étais parti en Inde à la frontière du
Cachemire on était en plein désert et
tout le monde nous disait surtout là-bas
faut pas boire l'eau
et au bout de quelques jours moi je
m'étais habitué je me suis dit tiens
j'aime prendre un petit thé
dans la minute
j'ai senti qu'il fallait pas boire l'eau
là-bas
pour moi
les autochtones sur place ils ont que
cette eau-là à boire il y a des millions
de gens sur cette planète qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable c'est important de
prendre ça en compte parce que c'est ça
aussi les besoins de temps en temps nous
avons des façons de nourrir nos besoins
qui sont impropres à notre consommation
mais comme on a que ça à manger
et ben on va s'en satisfaire peut-être
que dans nos sociétés ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est d'une reconnaissance plus
propre
cette carte de besoin elle met très
utile je vais vous montrer des exemples
de comment ça marche dans la vraie vie
de comment même moi même moi qui connaît
la carte de temps en temps je vais avoir
du mal à empêcher la satisfaction
négative de ses besoins
j'ai un client avec qui je travaille
depuis pas mal d'années maintenant à qui
j'ai enseigné cette carte des besoins
et
toujours on a passé toute la journée à
travailler
et au bout d'un moment moi quand on
passe toute la journée à travailler
j'ai un peu de mal j'ai un peu de mal à
connecter mon cerveau
alors de temps en temps j'ai la croyance
qui me faut un café et que ça va
repartir
là ce jour-là je me suis dit cherche je
vais aller à la machine à café je vais
me faire un petit café puis ça va
repartir j'arrive monsieur un café je
suis comme ça
voilà
cherche une pièce malgré moi je regarde
j'ai bien vu qu'il y avait une espèce
d'étiquette sur la machine à café mais
j'ai pas lu
je mets la pierre
et là j'ai Thomas qui me tombe dessus
je me suis targué de faire une petite
affichette de 12 cm par 12 cm que j'ai
plastifié moi-même sur laquelle j'ai
stipulé qu'il était important avant de
mettre la pièce de placer la tasse et je
parle bien de la tasse parce que il est
essentiel à l'heure d'aujourd'hui au
jour actuel que maintenant que nous
sommes engagés dans une planète qui se
veut écologique nous mettions plus des
gobelets tu comprends ça Michael
c'est pas bien compris parce que j'avais
oublié d'allumer mon cerveau et j'ai
fait
heureusement on l'a tous les deux la
carte des besoins et on a tous les deux
comprises qui se jouait malgré nous dans
cette relation lui il a un besoin de
reconnaissance pour son travail il a
besoin de sentir que son engagement est
respecté moi j'ai besoin de contact
c'est une façon d'en obtenir mais ça
marche pas tes masse
heureusement avec les années on a appris
à se connaître à mieux se comprendre et
à mieux se respecter malgré la
divergence de nos besoins
et on a acquis une complicité entre nous
qui fait que même si on met en place ces
comportements on arrive encore à se
respecter
c'est ça les besoins c'est important
parce que
parfois on peut avoir la carte mais la
carte n'est pas le territoire
sous-entendu que j'ai beau savoir le
chemin qui va falloir que j'emprunte de
temps en temps quand j'ai le choix entre
un beau chemin bien droit et un terrain
en terre battue tout pourri
j'ai envie de prendre le terrain en
terre battu tout pourri
il m'a raconté une anecdote parce que
lui aussi il utilise ça au quotidien et
il m'a raconté quand il rentre chez lui
avec sa femme Agathe
il était rentré chez lui et Agathe elle
avait passé toute une journée devant un
écran d'ordinateur
avec ce qu'elle appelle un robot
ce qui est difficile pour elle
et lui qui avait une journée
satisfaisante il rentre chez lui content
plutôt content de lui lui il a besoin de
cadre de structure il aime bien quand
les choses sont bien droites bien
rangées et il aime bien quand il arrive
à la maison que ça corresponde à ce
qu'il attend
c'était dur elle a besoin d'intimité
elle a besoin de relation et passer la
journée avec un robot pour elle c'est
compliqué
et donc elle se sentait pas très bien
elle avait laissé ses affaires sur la
table du salon elle s'était mis sur le
canapé avec une couverture
Thomas arrive il la voit allongée sur le
canapé et lui dit pensant être
bienveillant
qu'est-ce qu'il y a encore
Agathe
c'est encore
c'est pas la phrase parce que oui il
s'intéresse à moi mais le encore il a il
est lourd de sous-entendu vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est après cette
journée moi j'avais besoin d'intimité de
d'attention de bienveillance mais ce
encore il pèse lourdeur il y a un poids
dans le encore qui est terrible
elle lui dit
oh rien ça va je suis énorme je sais pas
Thomas tu sais pas
qu'est-ce que tu sais pas qu'est-ce qui
va pas mais non mais ça va je vais bien
enfin je vois bien que tu vas pas je te
dis que je vais bien laisse-moi
tranquille enfin tu vas pas m'agresser
alors que oh là là c'est terrible bah
c'est terrible c'était pas capable de me
dire ce que tu as mais je sais pas j'ai
un petit peu mal à la tête quoi voilà
ben voilà prends un cachet
mais c'est pas le cachet je te dis que
je fais pas bien et toi tu
c'est là que Thomas prend conscience de
ce qui se passe et grâce à la carte des
besoins il se recadre il dit oui c'est
pas le besoin de structure qui vient ici
il arrive il se pose à côté d'Agathe il
se met à son niveau sur le canapé et lui
dit tu sais chérie moi j'ai passé une
bonne journée et je voulais te dire que
je suis là pour toi si tu as besoin de
partager si tu as besoin qu'on discute
tous les deux ou peut-être qu'on peut
aller faire une balade même on va au
restaurant ce soir si tu veux
et là Agathe sous et souris
c'est souvent une histoire de
communication comment on arrive à parler
de nos besoins qui vont soulager la
situation
ça va c'est clair ça
vous avez déjà vécu ça
tu peux
dans la liste des autres besoins il y a
besoin contact je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure le besoin de contact satisfait
négativement ça peut typiquement être
l'enfant qui va voir sa maman maman tu
viens jouer avec moi maman tu viens
jouer avec moi ah chérie j'ai pas le
temps là tu vois bien que Maman
Travaille je suis en train de faire des
choses importantes moi des choses
d'adultes
le moment vient jouer avec moi s'il te
plaît viens jouer avec moi je joue avec
moi ça suffit oui
à jouer dans ta chambre tu as qu'à jouer
avec le jouet là qu'on t'a offert à Noël
mais moi j'ai plus besoin de contact
j'ai pas besoin de jouer
donc qu'est-ce que je vais faire sur le
chemin de la chambre c'est là où il y a
le vase Ming qui date de la 18e période
avant Jésus-Christ
je vais mettre un petit coup de pied
dedans histoire qui tombe histoire que
enfin c'est pas possible mais qu'est-ce
que tu as fait tu as cassé le
qu'est-ce que je voulais
tu contacte qu'est-ce que j'ai eu
tu contactes
ça marche comme ça j'ai besoin si
j'arrive pas à le satisfaire d'une
manière positive je satisfais quand même
il y a besoin de solitude besoin de ces
outils et assez paradoxal parce que je
vais me retirer
vous avez peut-être déjà eu des gens
autour de vous qui
se retirent dans le silence mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là pourquoi tu
parles pas pourquoi tu dis plus rien
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive je réfléchis
je réfléchis à la réflexion ce que je me
demande ce que je pense au moment où je
pense que je pense
c'est ce besoin là qui va falloir
respecter dans le besoin de solitude
comprendre que être dans le silence est
une ressource en soi
ce qui socialement est pas terrible à
accepter on le reconnaîtra
il y a besoin de reconnaissance pour les
opinions alors le besoin de
reconnaissance pour les opinions c'est
très clair moi j'ai des avis des avis
bien tranchées sur beaucoup de sujets
j'ai travaillé sur mes opinions depuis
que je suis né donc vous comprenez que
quand il s'agit de débattre je suis pas
le dernier c'est moi qui le dimanche en
famille va lancer le sujet polémique
forcément parce que moi ça me plaît et
les autres ils vont peut-être avoir un
petit peu plus de mal ceux qui ont moins
ce besoin disons que ce qu'ils ont moins
ils vont durer 5 minutes puis les autres
vont durer une heure et puis à la fin il
y en a plus que deux qui vont se
confronter sereinement en mode tiens et
si on se disait ce qu'on pense
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu quelqu'un
faire des croisades ne pas lâcher le
morceau vous faire du alors pourquoi
est-ce que tu ne penses pas comme moi
voilà les besoins je vous fais un
dernier exemple c'est le besoin
d'excitation qui est pas toujours
évident à reconnaître parce que la forme
change pas vraiment
en général dans son aperçoit une fois
que c'est passé que le besoin de
satisfaction d'excitation et nourries
négativement
moi je vous avoue qu'ici devant vous
besoin d'excitation besoin d'adrénaline
il est bien chargé
ma copine Léa
elle a tellement besoin avec citation
que quand elle fait deux jours de suite
la même chose pour elle elle appelle ça
de la routine
l'autre jour je la croise au bureau
j'arrive et elle me fait ah Mickaël
oui
la réunion ce matin
quelle réunion ah bah si tu étais pas
invité
de toi
vous avez parlé que de moi mais quelle
réunion enfin pourquoi vous avez parlé
de quoi je peux pas te le dire je peux
pas te le dire mais t'inquiète pas tu
vas entendre parler assez tôt
moi je suis comme ça là
le lapin dans les phares d'une voiture
j'ai peur qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi
je réfléchis à ma carte des besoins
Léa ça y est ça fait deux jours qu'elle
a pas vécu sa drôle d'adrénaline elle a
pas eu la charge qu'il fallait donc elle
va la créer et je tombe je passais par
là c'est pas possible c'est pas
spécifiquement parce que c'est moi mais
c'est juste j'étais là je passais dans
le couloir lui tiens je vais me le faire
besoin d'excitation c'est important pour
Léa de savoir qui va falloir qu'elle
aille faire un tour un saut en parachute
ou peut-être qu'elle vienne sur la scène
de Lannion pour le carré magique faire
un TX est chargé sa batterie à mort pour
pouvoir être bien dans la relation aux
autres
voilà ces messages que je voulais passer
aujourd'hui parce que savoir reconnaître
ses besoins savoir comment les nourrir
positivement plutôt que d'Hélène nourrir
négativement et primordial pour avoir
des relations saines avec les autres
primordial pour pouvoir se sentir bien
dans la relation avec les autres pour
éviter d'avoir des relations qui
deviennent piégeuses voire toxiques
parfois parce qu'on apprend à nourrir
nos besoins de manière négative avec des
jeux psychologiques dans nos relations
donc savoir les repérer dans les signes
avant-coureurs avant que ça devienne
trop tard c'est très important voilà ce
que je voulais vous parler aujourd'hui
ce dont je vous voulais vous parler
aujourd'hui il est important de se
connaître de se comprendre pour bien
comprendre l'autre et après pour bien se
comprendre ensemble dans la relation
c'est ça l'idée que je voulais vous
partager aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]